- So speaking of "The
Mummy", is it true that,
is this the one that you almost died?
- Nearly, well, I was
choked out accidentally.
There's a hanging sequence.
- I know what you're
talking about, the sequence.
I didn't know that that actually happened.
- Well, I don't remember
too, oh gosh, yeah.
- They tightened it so much that you,
like they had, like what happened?
- I was standing on my toes
like this with the rope
and you know, you only got so far to go.
And Steve ran over and he said,
hey, it doesn't really
look like you're choking.
Can you
sell it?
And I'm like, all right, fine.
So I thought, one more take man.
And the camera swooped around
and I went up on the toes,
and the guy holding the rope above me,
he pulled it up a little higher
and I was stuck on my toes.
I had nowhere to go but down.
And so he was pulling
up and I was going down.
And then the next thing I
knew, my elbow was in my ear.
The world was sideways and
there was gravel in my teeth.
And everyone was really quiet
and there was a stunt guy,
the coordinator was there
and he was going (claps)
Brendan,
Brendan, wake up.
And I'm like, oh, what,
what happened, what is this.
"Congratulations. You're in the club.
Same thing happened to
Mel Gibson on Braveheart."
- Oh my God.
- Thanks, I think.
I wanna go home.
- I love that he said
Mel Gibson in Braveheart.
Was he like accidentally gutted?
- I think he--
- Like, what was that?
- We're off to a blazing
start in this movie so far.
- Oh my gosh, that's scary.
I would've been like, the acting is fine.
I'm not choking for you.